text boy laid out on a laboratory floor
the astonishing contents of a whale's
stomach 30 bags and other pieces of
plastic that had clogged its digestive
system some of it food packaging almost
certainly from the UK the discarded
remains of someone's shopping the six
meter long cubillas beaked whale had
been in such distress when spotted off
the Norwegian coast that vets say they
had no option but to put it to sleep
the post-mortem showed it was badly
malnourished sort of workers on earth it
wasn't like it was in just a part of the
stomach it filled the whole space
I think the whale has been in pain I
don't think it's been comfortable to
have this in the stomach I think that
what lies here is an explanation of why
the animal acted so strangely and
stranded it's just burnt up all the fat
has died once more than 280 marine
species are known to eat plastic
including these seabirds filmed recently
by Sky News conservationists say we all
need to take more care when using and
disposing of plastic most of the items
that we find our items that have just
been used once and then just simply
carelessly disposed you know with no
thought of it being recycled or being
reused and for all its properties you
know the fact that plastic is such a
fantastic material at all you know it's
durable long lasting but this means that
it it doesn't actually disappear
particularly in the marine environment
Norwegian scientists believe the whale
had mistaken the bags of squid its
natural prey they're not surprised by
the stomach contents one rubbish truck
of plastic is dumped in the ocean every
minute and it's calming sea creatures
Thomas More Sky News
you